foreign
people welcome to the Honest Trailer
commentary for Speed Racer yeah that's
this week yeah go Speed Racer go go and
let's go through the motions of this I'm
here never excited to be here let's jump
in actually I'm excited because finally
Lana are usually on the same page of
stuff but uh we have some divisions on
this table and this is yes a freshly
Shore in lawn Harris looking good uh
looking man more aerodynamic you're
you're not you're used to seeing like a
whole bunch of nonsense going on here
and now you can see the the Honest
Trailer commenting his top speed is
actually through the roof right now yes
I'm running here I'm so much more
aerodynamic now it's crazy uh we're
gonna watch on his trailer and start and
stop when we have thoughts and feelings
about it uh we also have some deleted
scenes and we'll do a q a with any
questions or comments you might have put
those in the chat while we're talking
and we'll do that at the end and then
clue you in to next week's honest
trailer
should be a welcome respite that's
that's cool okay and I know the answer
yeah so uh but Speed Racer um a film
that I had heard mixed things about
um and had never seen myself oh this was
your debut this was your first Speed
Racer yes my first Speed Racer watch and
uh look if I saw this in the theaters
folks I was part of the initial I was
not a Johnny come lately to Speed Racer
I was like I'll say if I if I were
trapped in the theater and forced to
watch this movie start to finish
um I probably would like it less but I
think that this one reminds me of like
Tim and Eric's Billion Dollar Movie
where it's so so over stimulating and
there's so much going on in the frame at
all times that I was able to watch this
in like 40 minute chunks like three
during a day like I watch it for 40
minutes I took a break I let my eyes you
know like the tear ducts moist in my
eyes because they've been desiccated
watching like this candy colored
Nightmare and then uh and then I was
able to dive back in and enjoy it I
thought it was an insane cartoon yeah
much like the original which I loved so
I guess that also predisposed me to like
it because yeah I'm not familiar with
the Speed Racer uh Cartoon Series yeah
so this this is my only real exposure to
the lore yeah
no there's lore of speed I was reading
up on the manga there is a lot of lore
if you go back the movie doesn't really
touch on a lot of it but uh the the
cartoon I didn't read the Manga but the
uh the cartoon is a lot of people are
just murdering each other left and right
I mean that's consistent with the film I
think at one point in the movie uh a guy
just takes out a handgun and just starts
shooting at his competitors and then in
the next scene speed tells his dad had
the races are rigged and John Goodman's
like oh I don't believe that first say
like you saw a guy take out a gun during
League Play economically the racer
family are all idiots like they could
how could you be involved in the race
industry for generations and not know
that the Stanley Cup of racing was
rigged uh like how does he not know any
of that keeping that Chimp in a Suburban
household cruel a recipe for disaster
Chim Chim should not be there like like
leave him at the track maybe but not in
your house with that let's Dive Right In
uh to the honest trailer for Speeders oh
oh but what's this oh this is our 2023
Webby award oh gosh who left this here
ah it's a it's a great place to put your
beverage don't disagree don't do that no
I'm saying I'm saying I just I'm trying
to find ways to James Corden has one of
those now yeah
um but yeah thank you to the web he's in
for you for voting and uh this show up
in the mail so oh how nice what was our
what was our acceptance
it's betting on Webbie's money playing
we did it maybe gambling on rubbies yeah
it was something like yeah there's
nothing betting on Webbie's money
playing so yeah here's to
congratulations to us yeah
I feel like that's gotta be the first uh
Webbie's money plane reference right I
mean I feel like we now hold that
distinct well I wonder if when Darius
Emmanuel the Grouch three won his Webby
for his crypto show I'm taking down the
money plane
not on the money put down the money
yeah there you go we did it all right uh
let's watch the Australia let's watch
The Honest Trailer go
all right
[Music]
before you drive past Gran Turismo check
out a forgotten gym of a racing movie
that's so fast-paced and insane you'll
swear you're watching the original
cartoon
[Music]
[Laughter]
show is hardcore
stop crying it won't do any good in any
way you have a lot of work to do
starting right now yeah good advice
racer
after the Matrix sees the wachowskis
could do anything so they took a rave's
worth of Molly and entered their flop
era making Speed Racer a colorful box
office duh that's become a cult classic
Cloud Atlas a colorful box office door
that's become a cult classic and Jupiter
Ascending a colorful box of a stud
that's what really this one too I create
because like that it's it's that kind of
movie he's he's good it's not like he's
so bad he's good yeah he's plugged in
more than anyone else to the vibe of the
movie he's giving an appropriate
performance Channing Tatum way too
subdued everybody like Sean Bean I
usually like but way too subdued in this
he needs to be in an 11. everybody else
they put they put dog ears on change him
give him uh rocket skates and he's still
just the rest of them protect you my
queen the rest of them really need to be
matching red Mains energy I actually
think Mila Kunis is like she gets it to
like her role in it like I think she's
pretty good in it too it's everybody
else is just underplaying I like all the
uh abraxa siblings that's my that's my
succession
let's send Kendall into space to to chop
it up with the Abra but they never
questioned that they liquidate planets
to make D aging cream he's just in yeah
we just uh we just go for it you know
the cream yeah
full-on liquidate 12 planets or we're
creaming bro we're creamed or what
it's weird I feel like I feel like Speed
Racer is now the most loved like we've
gone back and reevaluated this whole era
of Wachowski and Speed Racer is the one
everybody loves the most is the one it's
the only one I don't like all the other
ones I'm like I'm like clad Atlas
certainly has its issues but there's a
lot of fun stuff in it too it's very
like crazy and over the top and
imaginative in a fun way this just like
10 minutes plus of it grates on me I
just can't take it I could see that but
yeah Jupiter setting don't get me wrong
it's still a really bad movie it's a
really bad movie watching experience I
don't know if I I agree it's crazy and
and chaotic and not uh like well
organized or structured maybe but like
so imaginative a lot of experts dump
after dump of lore and um but Eddie
Redmayne makes it all sing I I really
enjoy like I think it's a fun movie to
watch yeah all right it's got that Fifth
Element Vibe oh don't keep it back out
of your mouth in the same sentence as
Jupiter Ascending how dare you fair but
uh the red main cut I would watch
anytime yeah I just I was gonna say just
like without like like Fifth Element I
really enjoy but it balances the comedy
with this kind of like artsy
self-importance it's like European in
that way and I don't think Jupiter
Ascending has that it's just the
goofiness yeah agreed all right well I I
still I prefer I prefer the other group
yeah let's keep going
it's a fun 80 minute movie stretched
into a two-hour Tech demo that's like
eating a bowl of I can for breakfast
lunch and dinner in one of the earliest
examples of stick actors in empty rooms
and doodle the film behind them where
Adobe apps take the place of props sets
and lighting while the cast must make
everything feel real on acting skills
alone oh come on take me with you come
on please Rex please please please
please
please uh oh Where Have You Been have
any of these drivers read the rule book
oh no holy can only speed
I think that that might have been a
choice to uh oh yeah let's run it back
baby any of these drivers
that might have been a a decision to
emulate the tone of the cartoon yeah of
course I mean it it clearly is meant to
be really goofy and cartoonish and like
have that sort of broad over-the-top
feel but it really stands out when
you'll have like John Goodman and Susan
Sarandon like playing a scene and
they're acting yeah and then her she's
like I don't know maybe I should not go
in the race like it's very uh uh I think
it could have used a little more
emotional depth from some of the
characters yeah I mean I think I just so
much of the movie is montage and like
that's obviously a big part of what
they're like that was the idea is like
it's almost a whole movie with no scenes
that's just like constant wipes and
constantly everything is is happening in
a montage at the same time and you cut
to an announcer and then you cut to the
race and then you cut that at home and
then it's a flashback and it's just like
it does like when you do slow down for a
scene it is like now it feels
inauthentic and like quick speed it up
yeah like you're not you're not making a
real movie so you don't have that option
to just like pause occasionally and make
a real movie for five minutes yeah
experimental in a way that it never
never slows down it's on it's on brand
it is it is on branded I mean it is very
it wasn't very experimental in its in
its day I just I wish that uh I feel I
feel like we we all took the wrong
lessons from from this experiment like
the the thing that became rather than a
new approach to like editing or like
Montage or like different ways of
Storytelling the thing that we took from
this movie was put Christina Ricci in a
blue room and then paint them yeah we
don't need to build sets anymore right
and like any practical effects that's
gone so far in a I think negative
Direction now that I I don't want to
blame this movie for that but that that
sort of became the takeaway to me this
is the one movie not the one but the one
movie where
um the CGI doesn't look real but it's an
aesthetic Choice like they were trying
to make it look realistic no they're
it's not like the flash horror Dome
where they're like no we wanted it to be
that yeah and it and it looks cool I
mean there are there are genuinely
sequences in this where the like racing
especially during the races where it
does look cool like it doesn't look like
we're always complaining about the
volume or wherever where it just looks
flat and Bland like it's super bright
it's super colorful it's hyperkinetic
where it feels like there's movement in
every corner of the frame and like it's
cool like I'm not saying there's no cool
shots or moments I just man like so many
what when I saw sin city or when I first
saw Spy Kids when I saw a Sky Captain
right I saw this I you had so much hope
for what this technology could be and
then it ended up being this prison
now we've locked all of our actions
trapped in a blue case yeah they're sure
they're locked in a room involved into a
tennis ball yeah and it's just like man
we just like book this took things in a
bad Direction but that's not Speed Racer
journey to a world whose economy is 95
Car based and the rest is Segways and
the most popular sport is a mix of
Formula One and pro wrestling
[Music]
school as it sounds like they cause a
snake but the driver's gimmick is
calling people turds
a grade A [__]
luckily he's also the best driver alive
because what else could you do with that
name besides porn maybe
speed comes from a long line of expert
racists like his Pops Pops who runs an
entire high-tech racing team with a
staff of one live-in Australian house
boy I just can't believe there's not one
mention of racer Motors in here Rex
speeds uncle brother who doesn't want 18
year old age Gap stop him from sharing
the world's worst driving advice close
your eyes
Racer X a mysterious Matthew Fox who is
obviously Rex after faking his death but
there's a Twist he's not you're not Rex
but there's a Twist he is I wonder who's
burnt corpse he's stuck in his coffin
Trixie Christina Ricci in a bob so sharp
it should be called a Robert and the
comedic Duo of spiral and chimchim the
Annoying kid plus Jim Pals that will
instantly get on your nerves and stay
there
take him away boys
uh just remembering how much I like
Jordan peels know for no particular
reason
yeah that was a tough pill to swallow
was the shtick that they gave to do
they're at some point there was a
creative decision that was made that was
like let's give this 10 year old actor
just as many Vaudeville sticky 20s kind
of comedy routines as humanly possible
like let's give him one gay Herald game
to play percine and like I don't it's
not this poor kid's fault but like no
but they were he was carrying a lot yeah
he's too young he's too young to be
asked to constantly deliver this level
of comic material by himself he's only
acting opposite a chimp for most of it
like if they didn't even give him John
Goodman as a scene partner and they're
like come on man that's that that's not
fair to ask of a child too much too soon
yeah and it's just like it it does not
work and it's so by the end it's so
annoying like I I did not fast forward
because I take this job seriously I
found it very great
um I do it was it was leavened with the
fact that um I like him as chowder you
ever watch that cartoon he's the voice
of Chowder on what Cartoon Cartoon
Network long canceled oh I don't know um
so probably after my I found it more pal
but um still that was this is a long
film yeah and uh that's the other thing
if this was a 90 minute you're in and
out no film is a better candidate for
being nice yeah than this one yeah it
was just like making it epic length you
don't need to it doesn't even have a
plot why why drag it on like that that
well okay keep going
would you rather watch racing action
based on the most boring game since
Microsoft flights in
action based on f-zero plus Beyblades
in races that feel like watching an
earthquake at the Hot Wheels Factory
where the drivers basically try to kill
each other
but the real Scandal is that the winners
can briefly alter a stock price oh
Lookout speed you're facilitating
Royalton's corporate buyout only one of
us are helped to drive up a stock in his
family business yeah I feel like all the
murder is the bigger evil but he is
British so yeah I mean a for effort for
them to try to make this uh
anti-capitalist film about the malignant
corporate influence over racing and
stuff but that was completely lost on
not just the audience but on speed it
was like I don't know I just want to go
fast yeah I I had no stakes in the
overarching stakes of the of the film
which was this uh manipulating stock
price scheme that he never understood so
we didn't really care he just wanted to
win the stakes of the final race are
that he has to win in order to expose
this fraud that's the only way that they
could be sure they'll expose the fraud
as opposed to he needs to win because
he's got a personal rivalry against the
people he's racing against right which
is kind of sports movie well he's trying
to he's trying to like honor and and
catch his brother but the audience knows
that his brother's like right next to
him in the exaggeration and I just be
like like Rocky
fighting Apollo Creed they've spent the
whole movie having a rivalry it's deeply
personal by the time they fight we're
invested we want Rocky to beat Apollo
because he's a jerk yeah we were still
he was still killing um new cartoon
characters yeah and and speed raiser in
the final race there isn't that personal
stake it's like well Royalton's bad and
if we win this Wilton's not in a car but
he's right he's not he's there in an
office
like come on like this
is pretty obvious they just like have an
evil racing guy that he's gotta beat you
know and I forgot to add a rivalry his
Johnny Tran from Chinatown yes that's
first that's the Fast and the Furious
the first the first one
um oh well next time yeah yeah keep
going for one of the most secretly
influential films of all time that
shaped how all movies Would One Day
become green screen cartoons yeah does
it look cooler no it doesn't feel cool
but if it looks cool that's what matters
with trigger warnings for all physical
intimacy
the following image may be unsuitable
for the calculated or
cootie sensitive viewers and prove that
a franchise could be built on a
foundation of fast cars secretly working
for the government not making any sense
and family hey put that milk down grab a
Corona Sparky you're rolling with our
crew now
story Emil Hirsch at Sunday ends okay No
More Mr Nice Guy you ever race a
stranger in the house Susan sarand damn
Christina racy spider
chip my ride E Honda inside
Tokyo grift croyke racer Twitter Lars
von Tire David says love
and drive shaft Fast Times I'm really
high
I'd rather keep my mouth covered when
I'm in a convertible with my eyes these
dudes must eat like a million bugs
there you go true uh well there you go
that was the honest trailer for Speed
Racer an off requested uh film that I
never got around to seeing until now
um I'm amazed we never did this one
before because it is a it's an off
disgust movie on on the social media
weirdly we've also we did this because
we were thinking about oh Gran Turismo
racing movies what racing movies are
there but we also have yet to do V for
Vendetta for when the wachowskis
um next time I haven't have a Netflix
series out or something because I don't
know if they'll get another chance uh
probably not another Matrix movie
yeah the last one I really enjoyed it
most most people were not there to do it
didn't do that well right
um so I'd be curious how that one holds
up that's uh I I really like Matrix
resurrections no I mean V for Vendetta
oh uh yeah I haven't seen that in a
while yeah it's been a long time um but
Speed Racer that was Speed Racer I'm on
board I'd watch it if they did a
probably a video game would be better
than another movie for this one plays
like a video game
um there's so much more to explore in
the Jupiter Ascending verse I think we
gotta get back there first cousin Roy
Abraxas
definitely got it there's other
corporations in outer space come on
what's going on with them
um so she's the queen of Jupiter now and
Earth I guess oh right she's the queen
of our holes after sector of space yeah
yeah and bees recognize royalties
that makes I mean it makes perfect sense
if you think about it speak of animals
and bees uh we have another video on
this channel where we got a a real
um doctor of veterinary science to talk
about Spider-Man and um how the webbing
would come out of his butt yeah and um
Peter would have to shed his exoskeleton
to grow all sorts of disgusting but yeah
that sounds nasty but fun spider facts
about um what a real Spider-Man might be
like what what about Peter parked car
how would that Peter Park
okay for that one all right
um but yeah lots of cool stuff about
spider mating Mary Jane would would eat
Peter um unless he could run away she's
not a spider well if she were okay
so please check that out because that uh
that was really fun to do uh and then
for this film you probably have some
outtakes right let's check it out
story if you're not hers you're last dim
Toretto John Goodyear Thelma and or
Louise helicopter mod silly racer tricks
are for
skidsly Grease Monkey Gordy's Chrome
fast X Hit the Road Jack Fox on the Run
fell alive squeeze reference no Speed
Racer no
spies Kids 3D cartoon
seriously Fox on the Run who are we
hoping was going to get that 70s classic
I don't know did you write that no I
didn't write that Danielle yeah uh great
song but not not super relevant there
you go uh all right let's get into the
uh the amas because that is who we are
um American musicals American Music
Awards so Billy sending me them on slack
but they're also being popped into the
into the script
um some people were saying that uh that
uh spiral looks like could might look
like a 10 year old Lon Harris
he did Trevor did preface this by saying
no offense uh none taken I I was I was
not a a beefy kid I didn't beef up until
my teen years so I didn't I didn't
really look I was I was very small and
scrawny when I was uh 10 years old but I
but I don't take offense I I see I see
you see there is I get it I get it yeah
uh so let's see uh Luis says would you
blame this movie for the attention span
of gen Z or slash an indicator of what
was to come I wonder if gen Z likes this
movie I mean oh yeah yeah I mean this
movie has definitely had a a huge
reappraisal I feel like the internet in
general across demos like likes it now
um I mean I definitely think with Gen Z
there there is that like the amount of
movement and energy and quick cutting
and stuff that would be irritating to
people in previous generations like old
old man Gilbert and Harris here uh I
feel like gen Z's more into it because
they're just they're used to that like
flipping through Tick Tock and like
that's just more of they're they're just
media they've been in front of screens
and media a lot more than we were at
their age and so they're uh so I feel
like you see that more like the the
spider-verse movies also are like yeah
for me is a little overwhelming but for
younger people it's like yes this is
what media should be like yeah a lot of
questions along these same lines of
um well they're being a little mean
about it but uh what did the Wachowski
siblings what did they create Beyond The
Matrix that
is of quality or lasting relevance
Beyond you guys know the balance it's
incredible bound is like probably their
best movie I Am what else do they do uh
what did they what well they did the
three Matrix movies and then they you
know I think we've talked about most of
their stuff right V for Vendetta
yeah which they produce James mcteague
directed they produce but definitely
watch bound that is uh that is 100 I
think I think bound is probably my
overall favorite of their of their films
but I mean I think just about all of
their movies including this one which I
don't not my favorite I think have
things of value like I think they're
cool directors even when I don't love
the finished film because even like
Cloud Atlas like the putting white
actors in in makeup to make them I I get
what they were thinking you know it's
like this International throughout time
but all of the stories are connected and
we're all connected and so the same
actors playing roles and all the stories
makes that kind of intuitive sense but
it just doesn't look right and it's kind
of offensive and weird and so there's
some missteps in that movie but I don't
think it's a terrible movie it's not
like irredeemable well check out bound
and um people say sense8 is really good
oh yeah the Sensei their Netflix show is
really good too and it's just they're
always interesting like even if you
don't love a Wachowski movie they're
making interesting choices and they're
they're they're they're not coloring
within the lines and they're doing
things that are unexpected and taking a
lot of risks and that's why the Matrix
is good but it's also what makes even
their their maybe not as good as the
Matrix movies interesting and worth
watching definitely that's what I was a
great
um all right let's go down to some other
topics people want us to check in on the
actor and writer strike updates uh if
you recall the last if I recall the last
talks have felt fallen through miserably
and yes it seems like there's no real
progress on and no they're talking
there's there are talks but it seems
like every issue both sides are pretty
dug in on they're they're still pretty
far apart but the the most recent wga
amptp like the last time they sort of
vollied sent things back to one another
there is there is movement I think the
wga quote was not nothing but not nearly
enough so it's it's a I think it's a
it's a net positive the actors and
writers have not moved their demands are
unchanged and these studios are slowly
moving towards meeting either not there
yet but
I mean that that sounds like winning to
me right like and the fact that they've
hired this crisis PR team that's now
putting ridiculous stories about Carol
Lamborghini in the New York Times I
don't know if you've been following this
not really uh so last week the news came
out that the amptp has hired a crisis PR
you know the kinds of people that like
the same people lizzo is hiring right
now that's who they're hiring uh like uh
they're they're destroying us at the
press and then like a few days after
that story over the weekend the New York
Times around this like puff piece about
Carol Lamborghini the head of the amptp
that's like she's trying her best and
don't be mean to her on Twitter you guys
it was so obviously like a plan yeah the
the pr people called this reporter and
were like write a nice story about us
and he was like okay like I don't know
why you would do that but all of that
smacks of desperation and the writers
aren't doing that the actors aren't
doing that like Amy Adams is out there
clowning the studios with her arrival uh
protests on so I didn't see that now she
just wrote human on it
uh so anyway uh you know it feels like
all the momentum is on one side so we're
not at a solution yet and I would say it
doesn't look like this year like the
studios already seem to be planning on
this year is not happening so like
actors aren't going to festivals and
like we're we're putting Dune too today
yeah so like disappointing but I I think
it's all a positive sign that like even
if it's dragging on all the momentum is
on the creative side right now I don't
the studios don't have a leg to stand on
really so what have they got what
argument have they got like they got
nothing really
I don't know I the only thing I saw was
that they were kind of hoping to do
maybe an interim deal like just to kind
of Kick the Can down the road like
here's a little more money can we
revisit this in in three years a lot of
the strategy is to is like you know just
like in politics the idea is like you
you wedge the other side so you split
the other side so their their goal is
get the wealthy established showrunners
and Big Top writers they want to end the
strike quickly and get back to making
their millions of dollars so like turn
them against the lower level writers and
like even if the lower level Riders end
up quitting the industry and move back
to their Hometown to become Baristas
fine that's okay the amptp doesn't care
uh so far it doesn't look like that's
working like David Simon keeps going on
Twitter and telling them to go f
themselves regardless I mean he'll say
that I mean like like a blood Pizza it
doesn't seem like Phil Rosenthal and
Shonda Rhimes are gonna like break ranks
and like Taylor Sheridan may want to but
he's he's alone right now so uh so far I
don't think that strategy seems to be
working well sweet all right well we'll
keep you posted with if anything major
uh shifts and the actors they have not
since the actor strikes started they
haven't resumed talks so Duncan Crabtree
Ireland the the the sad guy said he's
they're willing they'll sit down anytime
but no no Outreach yet yep uh we'll
we'll end with this uh Jim one what's
the all-time greatest bad movie that's
become a cult classic it has to be
either the room or ski school
[Laughter]
classic I know some people want to see
us uh talk about ski school
um I mean you're a big fan I I I would I
would certainly re-watch I mean I would
say the one our last Webby speech was
bring back the horny ski comedy it's
true it's true yeah I have no interest
in revisiting ski school outside of my
personal time but I would like to write
an update of ski school I would like to
read there definitely should be like
what's the 2023 answer to
ski school Hot Dog the movie Aspen
extreme like this was a viable genre
that we should be bringing back I think
we can all agree on is it global warming
is that what it took from us
the the raunchy skills yeah
like slobs versus snobs oh it used to be
most movies 80s comedy that was like the
formula yeah yeah I I agree where we
need to bring back the snobs versus the
Caddyshack style yeah
uh what's the sport that we can do
pickleball we could do the slobs of
pickleball oh my God honestly you should
not be giving that egg I'm sorry you can
pitch that that like the moment when the
strike is so the moment the strike is
over I guarantee you people are writing
the pickleball snobs versus lousy that's
that's definitely gonna happen for sure
that's a Garrett that's a that's a lock
yeah so lock that one in for I was let's
get the strike result I was gonna say
though the one like so bad it's a good
movie that I feel like not enough people
have seen is Miami Connection oh God
incredible
I mean but hilarious like honestly not
even maybe so bad it's good maybe just
good it's good it's it's very um
naturalistic the filmmaking is kind of
like they kind of did a one take or a
rough cut that they just kind of printed
it's exactly what you want from that
kind of movie where it's like incredibly
sincere heart on their sleeves people
who love movies and wanted to make an
awesome movie and uh they did the bless
them they did their best they're it's if
you're not familiar with it it's about
um a rock band called is it dragon sound
yeah I think dragon sound and they tour
around they're also Taekwondo Masters
and they go fighting ninjas from City to
City there's I I I can't sum it up any
better than that that is exactly they're
a traveling band slash clan of ninjas
and their songs are all thematically
about using Taekwondo to fight didn't
destroy it it's fantastic uh we should
do that next week but it's a big maybe
maybe two weeks from now uh yeah next
week it's a it's a it's a vacation week
and we're gonna we're gonna be doing
something thematic for that
um and we hope you'll be back then
sojourn to shy town there you go my town
yeah Chat City so we'll see you there
and then thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]
thank you